oh yeah like when somebody want one time
this was [ __ ] seven years ago when
people try to make you uncomfortable
with some [ __ ] that they're gonna bring
up I [ __ ] love that I [ __ ] eat
that [ __ ] for breakfast bro I eat it up
I love it
one time I was at the Laugh Factory this
was [ __ ] years ago and this girl came
up to me in front of other people and
said to me hey you asked me to hang out
on she was a facebook friend and we were
[ __ ] whatever she was like yeah you
you asked me to [ __ ] hang out on
MySpace or [ __ ] Facebook or something
and she thought she was gonna make me
embarrassed in front of her friends and
I [ __ ] it felt I felt like I became
the Hulk and I looked at her and I said
yeah yeah yeah I did yeah
and I [ __ ] hung it out there too I
hung it out there to dry dude you're
gonna hand me some [ __ ] wet laundry
dude you're gonna hand me some [ __ ]
wet laundry like I don't have a [ __ ]
clothesline are you kidding me she
thought she was gonna [ __ ] make me
feel uncomfortable in front of a bunch
of guys and girls she came with at the
Laugh Factory about hanging out and she
thought I was gonna [ __ ] stand there
with a wet sweater like oh what am I
gonna do with this nope I [ __ ] looked
at her in the eyes and I said yup and I
threw that [ __ ] in the dryer and guess
what she felt [ __ ] stupid after that
she didn't know what to say she goes up
yeah dude you're gonna make me feel
uncomfortable
I got [ __ ] judo moves with that [ __ ]
man I've bombed in front of 450 people
at the Irvine improv you think that
you're gonna come up in front of seven
people and say hey I remember you used
to ask me to hang out on Facebook or
myspace and
me feel copy you think I'm gonna do a
hard swallow for that give me all the
laundry I'll dry it [ __ ] all it's not
it's not gonna work dude it's not gonna
work I love it I love that [ __ ] I eat
I'll eat it I'll [ __ ] eat it do it
I'll eat it I'll keep it in my stomach
for four hours wait till it [ __ ]
forms [ __ ] it out and deliver it back to
you baby
how about that I just these people when
people come up to me hey man what's up
what's up hey you don't remember my name
huh I look at him and I say nope hey how
about this be memorable I think we
talked about this on the podcast that
part but be bent be memorable if I don't
remember your name your fault
how about that if I don't remember your
name sure don't put the blame on me man
I'll dry laundry all [ __ ] day I have
clotheslines for weeks
what's my name
you don't remember huh I step sir do you
you understand I step closer to you and
you know when the handshake is supposed
to end it doesn't end there I grip you
can't get away hey what's up what's up
man how you doing all good hey Chris you
you remember our name huh oh we do it my
head I'm holding it and I'm stepping in
and I'm
saying no that's how it should be it's
not my fault
I forgot your name and guess what if I
met [ __ ] the guy who cured cancer and
he said hey what's up I'm Rick I'll
never forget that guy's name
you know why memorable you know why smeb
all okay if I remember some [ __ ] dump
truck of a man if if some dump truck of
a man comes up and it already knows me
and I already met him and he says what's
my name huh hey who are you who are you
hey do you live in [ __ ] Albuquerque
cuz who are you
where the [ __ ] lives in Alcor
Albuquerque guys like that guys who you
forget their names
sorry Albuquerque had to pick some city
seal all that [ __ ] aren't working
[ __ ]
Albuquerque yeah dude you're not blaming
[ __ ] me for not knowing who the [ __ ]
you are dah dah dah dah yah I'm loving
it